we have a question also one of your
readers in Stockholm wants to see more
of the lands of the south
do you have any plans like soft arrows
are there how do you pronounce that
we're gonna hear more about that
probably not I mean maybe an occasional
cryptic sentence here and there that you
know the old Linda will put on their
their Westeros masters page and their
bullet lists that they have there you
can just wave if you want them - bullet
lists for the beginning of course of the
world of Ice and Fire you know I mean
when I'm about to write something about
norvos I go to their page and say what
if I said about norvos all right I've
said that everybody there has a pet
grasshopper and and they talk backwards
okay it was tough to you know like it
okay now I write the histories of nine
free cities and there were some cities
where there were quite a few things that
I could use that there were other cities
where there was basically nothing about
you yes they keep pet grasshoppers they
talk backwards that was all that was so
I had to make up stuff yeah that was one
of the parts that was like as we started
writing the were always the fire became
to us like increasing fear we thought
we'll just get a few notes from you and
we'll fill out the rest based on some
notes and we realized like there was
such a disparity between certain regions
that you had like a lot about Braavos
for example and you had an almost
nothing but more off and so that way
like how are we gonna what kind of note
so we're gonna get from George to kind
of resolve that and what we got instead
was thousands of thousands of words
about these magnificent wonderful things
and and we would wake up in the morning
George when you sent it to us I guess it
was evening for you it would be
early morning for us we'd be getting up
at like 5:00 a.m. to say as Georgeson
does now it's very exciting that you
know the present-day mysteries and Ice
and Fire will be resolved mostly but I
also like a certain but you know the
ancient histories of you know what what
lies beyond the dark curtain and where
the gods came from no I'm not gonna
bring any gods on on stage I'm not gonna
give you a complete history of Sethe
oreos
you know you the mysteries of yeen will
have to remain mysterious and and for
people to you know to wonder about
themselves I think they're they're left
better that way a little a little more
mysterious and and cool
was I going to say about them the
mysteries of yeah I do also believe in a
certain amount of ambiguity and and
subtlety you know going through this
museum you look at the display on
King Carla 12th who was shot in the head
and no one knows whether he was shot in
the head by the enemy or his own men we
don't know that it's ambiguous it's
right there in this play maybe he was
killed by the Swedes and maybe but in
Norwegians he was fighting who killed
them we'll never know so if that's true
in life why shouldn't be true in fiction
you know what happened to the two
princes in the tower you know people
were arguing about that you know five
hundred years later who killed them were
they killed
well they smuggle that and say of to
knows why shouldn't we have similar
mysteries in fiction that we can argue
about and wonder about since they exist
in real life